saying zion pg what an incredibly
hard-fought game
this was tonight this jazz team would
not go away
you had six different players and double
figures can you describe the resiliency
that your squad showed
playing this game without kawhi leonard
tonight yeah this was uh
i i thought this was our toughest uh
matchup this postseason um this is the
biggest game of our of our season
especially being down our best player
we wish kawhi uh the best in the speedy
recovery but
uh we knew coming into this we had we
had to play together we had to step up
um but we didn't have to to over redo it
i thought everybody played their roles
we did a great job we played
collectively
and um against this team you have to you
know we limited our turnovers and i
thought that's what was the key tonight
when you took a look at the first half
they shot lights out then in the second
half
you held them to just three made threes
in the entire second half
defensively what was the key there
stick with it i mean i thought a lot of
their threes were tough ones
we didn't overreact they came out hot
good thing about it was we was able to
rather that weathered the storm
we came down we attacked him on offense
as well
we just took their blows we took their
punches but
i know we just thought they couldn't
sustain that over a full 48 game
when you take a look at where this
series now is you go up 3-2
you're heading home you are one game
away from heading to the western
conference finals
what's it going to take to close this
thing out at home
put this one behind us get ready for uh
you know a rocking crowd back in la
unbelievable opportunity we got waiting
for us back home
we just got to go into the mindset that
we don't want to come back to utah
pg congrats thank you hey mommy dad